here's your Chi try to get all you love
bachelor Chris I hope he can dance that
doesn't look so prom doesn't look
surprised
Fox ticket time is running out he has to
get ready for a Monday's premiere of
Dancing with the Stars now one thing he
doesn't have to worry about is mixing up
his fiancee and his dancing partner cuz
they're both named whitney says whitney
maggoty is gonna be like Whitney tell me
to do this wouldn't he thinks destiny
would be like which would mean alright
well Chris is the first to admit that
he's not a natural born dancer so is
Whitney the reigning ballroom champ were
talking about the dancer yes is she
whipping him into shape I was like
surprised that he actually has some
clothes but you gotta say this farmer
does have heart in his step when he
actually nails a move okay some stiff
competition this year especially
Nastia Liukin yeah olympic athlete
farmer
chris is actually the third bachelor to
do dancing and it looks as if getting
paired up at last season champ Whitney
it's getting him to show a lot of
personality perhaps more we saw then on
The Bachelor but nope she is not a fan
of Chris's very rural hometown where
they had their first rehearsal I had a
better Iowa it was freezing we went to
his brick farm she wants to move there
unfortunately this one big one see he's
really trying it Chris and his fiance
the other Whitney will be staying in LA
while he works it I feel like if I'm
gonna actually do okay at this whole
dancing thing I need to focus and be
here and really commit to it so I'm here
till they send me home I guess
you